[Musique]
quand je suis venu ici, la plage en était une
immense plage avait de bons restaurants
bons hôtels
tout et la mer Eh bien peu à peu la mer s'en va
a récupéré
[Musique]
et cela fait, disons, que le
les populations doivent partir
perdre tout son tout son
infrastructure vrai à la fois du sujet de
logement ainsi que la question de
métiers parce que nous savons qu'ils sont
communautés qui, d'une manière ou d'une autre
ils survivent grâce au tourisme
[Musique]
nous avons regardé avant qu'il y ait des troupeaux de dauphins
il y avait des requins ils ont manqué d'épées
mérous de quintal devant maintenant déjà
tout a été perdu à cause de la déforestation
de la flore et de la faune
[Musique]